on chainmail and steel plate over the
chest metal gauntlets over the hands and
Greaves over the legs a visored helm
over the skull a knight in full armor
can shrug off swords spears and axes but
Valyrian steel slices through his
protections like so much cloth as
advanced design is from bronze so is
Valyrian steel from ordinary steel
lighter yet stronger and nothing holds
an edge like it if you take a whetstone
to a Valyrian blade you'll need another
whetstone and maybe another hand to hold
it nobody knows how the Valyrians forged
their steel less than a handful of
Smith's can now even reshape it the
process like so much of their
civilization was lost in the doom many
claim they wove magic spells into the
molten metal and blasted it with dragon
fire when you see a Valyrian blade smoky
and dark as if drinking in the Sun and
rippling with a thousand folds you may
not scoff so loudly the Valyrian steel
that exists now is all there will ever
be some survives in the Citadel but the
maesters chains were a link of Valyrian
steel signifies study of the higher
mysteries whatever those are some drifts
through the world as prized daggers and
jewelry for rich merchants I've even
seen a Dothraki
barukh but much more a Valyrian steel
lives on in the great houses of Westeros
as their most treasured possession a
sword passed down from father to son for
generations ice of House Stark
heart's pain of house Tarly lady for law
of house Corbray but even precious
treasures can be lost
Aegon Targaryen 's Blackfyre and Visenya
x' dark sister disappeared and daemon
Blackfyre rebellion a foolish king of
the rock took house Lannisters bright
roar to Valyria and neither blade nor
man was seen again and then the rather
swords that are not lost but lose their
owners for five centuries long claw was
the pride of house moment my house even
penniless and in great debt I chose to
sell men rather than the sword and when
my shame became known and I fled Bear
Island for the east I left it behind for
my father to hold it for a worthier heir
Valyrian steel is a wonder of the world
sharper than wits truer than men rarer
than virtue but even its edge cannot cut
so deeply as a suns failure nor its
value match that of redemption